one of the reasons I got into studying
relationships was because I wanted that
right so I'm a scientist but I also love
art and I love writing and I love
literature I wanted to know that true
love could be real but as a scientist I
am cynical I just need some data and
when so I practice the type of therapy
called the gottman method and I love
that because it tends to be well it is
one of the most evidence-based therapies
we have based on John and Julie gottman
two psychologists who have been
researching relationships for now about
50 years and this therapy happens to be
for couples they found that you
absolutely can make longevity work in a
relationship you can build you are not
just settling for companionship but you
can have passion and intimacy and
growing love and appreciation but there
is a blueprint a set of skills that we
were never given we're not taught it in
school we change the rules of the game
and we haven't learned the rules yet
and uh the goblin method for couples
therapy kind of gives you a few
guidelines the rules for longevity in a
relationship yeah they did a beautiful
job at taking these findings they had
through you know Decades of research
quantifying it and then codifying it
into a therapy method it's really skills
based I tell couples when they're
starting out with me that they're
essentially going to be starting a class
so what's the five to one Golden Rule
what I read is there's the kind of
balance you can achieve of
uh how many interactions you have in a
relationships that are positive versus
negative and I think that's what the
five to one means but basically there
should be a kind of an empirical
like if you just look back over over a
month how many of the interactions were
positive how many day or the day
right so the the idea of this ratio
um well it's not an idea it was a
finding it is uh research finding that
the gottman's got after looking at
thousands of couples
um and codifying these interactions that
they were observing couples that tend to
be satisfied in their relationships
um that are happier they have better
health Etc they are having approximately
five positive interactions to each
negative and I want to be clear about
what I'm defining as positive and
negative here so this doesn't
necessarily mean that you're these don't
need to be big sweeping romantic
gestures buying flowers having sex these
are things like paying attention to what
we call your partner's bids we make
these bids for affection for connection
all the time in our relationships not
just with our partners but with our
friends our co-workers and we may not
even know what our style a bit is but if
you see them on a sheet you can pretty
quickly identify them bids could be
wanting to show your partner tell your
partner something and have them be proud
of you it could be wanting to go buy
groceries with your partner doing things
together hey you want to come with me it
could be telling a joke and hoping that
your wife looks up from her email on the
computer and acknowledges it if she
laughs then you've got a positive but if
I don't even look up that's a negative
right so it's not necessarily that I'm
calling my husband an it's just
am I connecting with him am I meeting
those bids for connection and vice versa
but do those also give you a guide of
how you should behave
well I think what's really important is
actually asking your partner or paying
attention to what your partner's bids
are because what matters to Ty my
husband may not matter to you for
instance I mean Ty's bar is so low with
me I thank God in terms of what defines
the positive interaction right like he
just wants me to ask him if he wants a
water when I get up to get myself one
just be a basic decent considerate
person is all he has sent me whereas
mine might be sort of like stay up later
with me watch a show go to bed at the
same time as me or um know about the
people in my life that sort of a thing